Optimal.
At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
so does brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the
people I've interviewed,
world class performers across
the military, entertainment,
sports, and beyond all have some
type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and
years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and
technology can help you.
This change comes through
guided meditation and
headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple,
so what I recommend is that you
take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands
of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try
it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the
founder Andy Puddicombe, a Ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million
views. His last name is p. U. D. D.
I. C. O. M. B. E. If you want
to look that up, but otherwise,
download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their
take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation. Completely free. 10
minutes a day. That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just
go to headspace.com forward slash. Tim
this episode is brought to
you by Wealthfront and this
is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive,
in a good way, set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists
from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last
two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars
under management. In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions
of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is, why? Why is
it so popular? Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams, et cetera. And
I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz,
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they'd put you in.
And if you just want to take their advice,
run with it, do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
And here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a
regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with.
Like automatic tax loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods
of time. Wealthfront, as I mentioned,
since it's using software
instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low
costs that were previously completely
impossible.
Right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim that
is less than $5 a month to invest a
$30,000 account for instance.
Now normally when I have a sponsor on
this show is because I use them and
recommend them.
In this case it's a little different.
I don't use wealth front yet because
I'm not allowed to. Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are
not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end
have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront
that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money, at least for me,
uh, in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope
to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation
as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free
if you decide to open an account,
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes, fill out their
questionnaire@wealthfront.com
forward slash. Tim.
It's fast, it's free. There's
no downside that I can think of.
Now I do have to read
a mandatory disclaimer.
Wealthfront Inc is an SEC
registered investment advisor.
Investing in securities involves risks
and there's the possibility of losing
money. Past performance is no
guarantee of future results.
Please visit wealthfront.com to read
their full disclosure. Check it out guys.
This is one of the hottest,
most innovative companies coming out of
Silicon Valley and they're killing it.
They've become massively popular.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create
for you and you can use that information
however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
It is usually my job to deconstruct
world class performers of some type,
whether they are from sports,
military, chess, entertainment,
God knows where they come from everywhere
and you find a lot of commonalities
across them.
This episode though is a special episode.
I'm going to hand the mic over to Seneca,
the younger and what you are going to
hear is roughly 2000 years old and it
teaches you how to deconstruct
or construct a world class life.
And suffice to say,
Seneca and his letters,
I've had an enormous impact on my
life. I revisit his writing, uh,
many dozens of times per year and this
particular letter has affected me in
myriad of ways,
litter 18 on festivals and fasting.
And I want you to pay particular attention
to a few passages that began around
two minutes and 20 seconds in with the
line set aside a certain number of days
and what this will teach you and Elucidat
is how to practice poverty and reduce
fear.
Specifically,
you can think of it as
inoculating yourself against
fear by practicing the worst
case scenarios.
This is a an incredibly powerful concept
that you can rehearse the things that
you fear to take the fear away
from them and out of yourself.
It is extremely practical and I
do this with short term fasting,
which of course you shouldn't
do without medical supervision.
I'm going to say that I'm not a doctor,
don't play one on the Internet.
I do that with wearing the same clothing
for instance and like white tee shirt
and jeans for a week or so. Or you
could do it by eating very cheap food,
rice and beans for instance,
two to $3 a day in total cost for a week,
but I will let Seneca get into it because
he will do a much better job than I
could ever dare to attempt. I implore
you to listen to more of these letters.
The 27 hours or so of audio that I
just put out is in the Tao of Seneca.
This is not a big money maker for me.
It's something I've wanted to do for
decades just to make these letters
available to you guys in
audio format so you can do it.
Say on the way to coffee or on the way
to work once per day in the morning,
you can digest one of these letters
and they can set you up for optimal
performance in high stress situations
so you don't overly react and hurt
yourself and others.
So you can check out the
town of seneca@audible.com
forward slash Tim's books.
Check it out.
You can listen to samples.
And for those of you who
downloaded it a few days ago,
there was an issue with the longer
on the shortness of life essay.
So you can skip that.
We're going to be removing it,
but all the other letters
should be in fine form.
And this is one of my favorites. Like I
said, letter 18 on festivals and fasting.
Pay Attention. It's changed my life. I
think he can do the same for you. And uh,
if you want additional resources, I will
try to include them in the show notes.
So four hour work week.com forward
slash podcast and check out the town of
seneca@audible.com forward
slash Tim's books. Enjoy
letter h on festivals and fasting.
It is the month of December and yet the
city is at this very moment in a sweat
licenses given to the general merrymaking
everything resounds with mighty
preparations as if the Saturnalia differed
at all from the usual business day.
So true.
It is that the difference is nil that I
regard as correct at the remark of the
man who said once December, it
was a month. Now it is a year.
If I had you with me,
I should be glad to consult you and
find out what you think should be done,
whether we ought to make no change in
our daily routine or whether in order not
to be out of sympathy with
the ways of the public,
we should dine and gay or fashion
and off the Toca as it is now.
We Romans have changed our dress for
the sake of pleasure and holiday making
though in former times that was only
customary when the state was disturbed and
had fallen on evil days.
I am sure that if I know you are
right playing the part of an umpire,
you would have wished that we should be
neither liked the liberty cap wrong in
all ways.
Nowhere in all ways unlike them,
unless perhaps this is just the season
when we ought to lay down the law to the
soul and bid it be alone in refraining
from pleasures just when the whole mob
has led itself go and pleasures for this
is the surest proof which a man can get
his own constancy if he neither seeks to
things which are seductive and a lower
him to luxury nor is led into them.
It shows much more courage to remain
dry and sober when the mob is drunk and
vomiting,
but it shows greater self control to
refuse to withdraw oneself and to do what
the crowd does, but in
a different way. Thus,
neither making oneself conspicuous nor
becoming one of the crowd for one may
keep holiday without extravagance.
I am so firmly determined. However,
to test the constancy of your mind,
that drawing from the
teachings of great men,
I shall give you also a lesson set aside
a certain number of days during which
you shall be content with a scan,
TST and cheapest fare with coarse and
rough dress saying to yourself the while
is this,
the condition that I feared,
it is precisely in times of immunity
from care that the soul should toughen
itself beforehand for occasions
of greater stress and it is wild.
Fortune is kind that it should
fortify itself against her violence.
In days of peace,
the soldier performs maneuvers,
throws up earthworks with no enemy in
sight and wearies himself by gratuitous
toil in order that he may be
equal to unavoidable toil.
If you would not have a man
flinched when the crisis comes,
train him before it comes,
such as the course which
those men have followed,
who in their imitation of poverty have
every month come almost to want that they
might never recoil from what
they had so often rehearsed.
You need not suppose that,
I mean meals like to moans or poppers,
huts or any other device which luxuries
millionaires use to beguile the tedium
of their lives.
Let the pallet be a real
one and the course cloak.
Let the bread be hard and grimy.
Endure all this for three
or four days at a time,
sometimes for more that it may be a test
of yourself instead of a mere hobby.
Then I assure you my dear Luke Ileus,
you will leap for joy when filled with
a penny worth of food and you will
understand that a man's peace of mind
does not depend upon fortune for even when
angry she grants enough for our needs.
There is no reason,
however,
why you should think that you were doing
anything great for you will merely be
doing what many thousands of slaves and
many thousands of poor men are doing
every day.
But you may credit yourself with this
item that you will not be doing it under
compulsion and that it will be as easy
for you to endure it permanently as to
make the experiment from time to time.
Let us practice our strokes on the dummy.
Let us become intimate with poverty so
that fortune may not catch us off our
guard,
which will be rich with all
the more comfort if we once
learn how far poverty is
from being a burden.
Even Epicurus the teacher of pleasure
used to observe stated intervals during
which he satisfied his
hunger in niggardly fashion.
He wished to see whether he thereby fell
short of full and complete happiness,
and if so,
by what amount he fell short and whether
this amount was worth purchasing at the
price of great effort.
At any rate,
he makes such a statement in the well
known letter written to poly noose in the
Orrcon ship of Karina Rhinos.
Indeed,
he boasts that he himself
lived on less than a penny,
but that Metro Dorros who is
progress was not yet so great.
Needed a whole penny.
Do you think that there can
be fullness on such fair? Yes,
and there was a pleasure also not
that shifty and fleeting pleasure,
which needs a Philip now and then,
but a pleasure that is steadfast
and sure four though, water,
barley meal and crusts of barley bread,
or not a cheerful diet,
yet it is the highest kind of pleasure
to be able to derive pleasure from.